chers amis
je vous demande maintenant d'accueillir
quelqu'un dont chacun sait que le choix
qu'il a faits en 2017 a été décisif pour
le pays et non je veux que ça qu'un
sache quel rôle décisif il a eu
aujourd'hui pour l'émergence de cette
force nouvel ensemble citoyens qui est
au fond son dessein celui de consolider
cet espace central dans la vie politique
du pays cher françois je te dire que je
suis fier d'ouvrir avec toi
cette nouvelle page
je ne vais pas énumérer les
remerciements
nous avons vu toutes les équipes qui se
sont réunis ici
et je veux à mon tour simplement les
saluer les remercier de leur action chef
des responsables des mouvements
politiques chefs des groupes
parlementaires
et les collaborateurs et collaboratrices
qui les accompagne partout parce que
sans eux nous ne pourrions pas arriver à
construire
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est
ce qui est frappant c'est que cette
assemblée cette réunion 7 ce meeting à
succès nous avons réuni en quelques
jours j'allais presque dire en quelques
heures
et ce lancement ce moment clé il a une
raison c'est que nous avons décidé de
faire ensemble un pas décisif vers la
constitution d'une force de
rassemblement pour soutenir la
réélection du président de la république
et pour préparer les grandes échéances
non pas des élections mais des
générations qui viennent
[Applaudissements]
nous savons
nous savons la charge et la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre
nous savons très bien que les immenses
problèmes que nous avons devant nous
tous les jours les problèmes liés à
l'immigration
les problèmes liés à l'outre-mer les
problèmes liés à la perte d'un grand
nombre de parts de marchés industriels
et de production nous ne les avons pas
créer nous les avons hérité c'est les
équipes précédentes qui si je ne me
trompe pas ont signé les différents
traités
le touquet dublin c'est les équipes et
les générations précédentes qui ont
laissé la guadeloupe sans eau pendant
des décennies c'est notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui
face une dégradation qui remonte si loin
c'est notre responsabilité que de
relever le défi et cette responsabilité
est immense et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes là parce que nous avons décidé de
construire une force pas seulement un
club pas seulement une entente mais une
force où nous allons travailler ensemble
pour donner à notre pays l'élan est l'
équilibre nécessaire pour garantir son
avenir l'élan est l' équilibre et nous
savons une chose que vous témoignez tous
ici c'est que cela ne se fera pas sans
les français sans l'engagement des
français or les français ont du mal avec
les chapelles l'île n'ont pas le temps
est très souvent ils n'ont pas envie de
scruter nos différences et de démêler
nonu ans ils veulent que nous nous
entendions entre gens de la même
inspiration et que nous avancions
ensemble
et c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé ce
rassemblement
et nous étions face à de nécessité qui
n'était pas facile à concilier la
première nécessité c'était le
rassemblement le plus large et le
deuxième c'était le dynamisme plus grave
le plus grand
tout le monde dans le même ensemble
et ce pendant qu'on avance
alors nous avons réfléchi nous est
apparu que cette question
élargissement ou approfondissement cette
question là avaient déjà été traités
dans l'histoire et c'est le principe
même de la construction européenne
alors nous avons retrouvé cette
inspiration
qui se déclinent très simplement et qui
vont être qui va être notre principe
d'organisation
tous les partenaires s'accordent sur des
règles minimales
mais tous acceptent le principe que
certains puissent aller plus avant et
plus vite qu'il y ait des coopérations
en europe ses fans on appelle ça des
coopérations renforcées ou des
coopérations avancée ce qui nous permet
de saluer çà n'a pas encore été fait les
députés européens qui sont là
voilà nos règles et je voudrais vous
rendre compte des cinq règles que nous
avons accepté et autour duquel nous nous
sommes regroupés la première de ces
règles c'est l'adhésion à la charte des
valeurs je pense qu'on vous a distribué
la charte des valeurs nous avons défini
dans cette charte précisément ce à canon
j'entends du brouhaha
stanislas guérini m'avait garanti que
vous les trouverez sur les fauteuils
[Applaudissements]
ce à quoi nous croyons tous ensemble
ballan vous le trouverez à la sortie si
vous n'avez pas trouvé à l'entrée c'est
comme ça que jérémy se rattrape de ses
erreurs et dans l'est
[Applaudissements]
ce à quoi nous croyons tous ensemble et
d'abord à cette notion de citoyen qui
avait été oubliée depuis longtemps mais
qui dit quelque chose de tout à fait
essentiel un citoyen qui est le chaînon
manquant entre démocrates et
républicains
un citoyen c'est quelqu'un qui proclame
qu'il est responsable il ne rejette pas
la responsabilité sur d'autres comme on
aime tant à le faire dans d'autres pays
ils assument ils participent il s'engage
il le fait sur le changement climatique
il le fait sur l'économie de liberté de
progrès il le fait sur le contrat social
c'est ce civisme responsable qui fait
notre différence
et nous disons en même temps qui nous
sommes
c'est à dire des humanistes affirmé au
moment
du manistes
humaniste au moment où toutes les
valeurs humanistes sont attaqués et
pervertit la laïcité la compréhension
mutuelle le respect au-delà des origines
des couleurs de peau des convictions
religieuses ou philosophiques
c'est le socle de la république que nous
construisons ensemble et c'est cet
humanisme qui nous défendra
et les bisons enfin que la france la
france notre france avec son modèle et
son idéal et que l'europe avec son unité
de civilisation on dans la crise du
monde un rôle décisif à jouer voilà nos
valeurs voilà notre combat
deuxième engagement dessin que nous
avons choisi l'affirmation de notre
mobilisation commune derrière celui qui
sera notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
permettez-moi de tête vous pouvez oui
vous attendiez que je dise son nom
l'heure n'est pas venue
mais permettez moi de m'arrêter un
instant à ce sujet qui paraît évident
mais qui pour nous tous présents dans
cette salle est centrale
c'est un secret dans ma vie politique
j'ai souvent était déçu et amer des
présidents de la république qui
précédait 2017 or j'ai comme vous mais
j'ai attentivement scrutés depuis 2010
est la pensée et l'action des manuels
macron
et je veux vous dire et je vais vous
dire ceci
pas une seule fois pendant ces cinq ans
pas une seule minute dans les
circonstances si difficiles que nous
avons traversés les affaires diverses et
variées li gilet jaune l'épidémie pas
une seule fois je n'ai pensé que je
préférerais quelqu'un d'autre que lui
dans cette responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
et je veux
et je veux tout simplement vous dire
pourquoi je veux tout simplement vous
dire pourquoi d'abord
parce qu'il a quelque chose qui n'est
pas si répandue il est courageux il n'a
pas peur ils affrontent il s'avance au
contact des événements et des hommes
ensuite il a une puissance de travail
impressionnante une mémoire
encyclopédique des dossiers les
discussions poussées incessantes autour
de l'expertisé de l'expérience
jusqu'à des heures trop avancée de la
nuit
et puis contrairement à ce qu'on dit
souvent
tu un témoignage c'est une affirmation
contrairement ce qu'on dit souvent
c'est hors des cercles de privilégiés
qui se sent le mieux parce que c'est un
homme de regard un homme de sensibilité
on peut se taper dans la main et je vous
invite à regarder ou à être attentifs au
regard qu'il porte sur les enfants y
compris les plus fragiles
et en plein
il a une vision
qui fait qu'en france comme dans le
monde tout le monde sait qu'il y à la
tête donne de notre pays et s'exprime en
son nom une volonté et une pensée qui
embrasse et qui affronte les grands
enjeux du monde tout le monde le sait en
europe et sur la planète
et comme il ne faut jamais oublier que
dans une élection de cet ordre on ne
vote pas d'abord pour une étiquette on
vote pour une personne au moins autant
que des bilans qui sont bons et les
programmes dont je ne doute pas qu'ils
seront pertinents et attrayant je vous
invite à défendre la personne de celui
qui sera notre candidat
troisième engagement
nous soutiendrons les mêmes candidats
aux élections législatives
même si le temps n'est pas venu de les
désigner ce qui veut dire que nous nous
entendrons chacun proposera et défendra
les siens et tous ensemble nous
soutiendrons les meilleurs ainsi
l'énergie disponible sera déployé pour
gagner du terrain
pour mener le combat contre les
adversaires déclarés
et pas pour des bisbilles entre nous
au passage
un petit mot un petit mot sur les
bisbilles dont beaucoup rêvent qu'ils
pourraient polluer notre action
alors je vais vous dire quelque chose de
simple nous n'avons ni le temps ni
l'énergie à perdre pour nous diviser
il peut arriver
il peut arriver que nous ayons des
différences des visions différentes de
l'avenir je ne ne fait pas mystère pour
ma part des miennes je suis pour notre
unité la plus grande possible et que
cette unité se transforme le plus vite
possible en une force politique unitaire
au service de nos idées non pas
seulement pour affronter une élection
mais pour les générations qui viendront
ma conviction est que aucun d'entre nos
mouvements tout seuls n'y arrivera et je
suis même partisan que sur ce chemin
d'unités que nous avons à parcourir il y
est une avant garde et que tous ceux qui
le souhaitent puissent se former d'ores
et déjà cette avant-garde vers l'unité
c'est ma conviction
est ce que c'est la seule non certains
parmi nous sont plus prudents plus
circonspect mais c'est comme dans la vie
entre le nord et le sud entre l'alsace
et la provence entre les pyrénées et la
normandie cher edouard il y à des
climats et des cultures différentes et
c'est ensemble que nous sommes la france
est que nous devons vivre ensemble pour
avancer ensemble
je récuse
je récuse les divisions chacun avancera
à son rythme c'est le contrat que nous
avons d'une certaine manière signé entre
nous et je suis sûr que nous nous
accorderons parce que ce dont nous avons
la charge nous dépasse et nous oblige
4ème engagement essentiel très rapide
nous acceptons tous je viens de le dire
que certains aillent le plus loin plus
vite et soit plus unitaire ce sont les
coopération avancée que nous pouvons
définir librement entre nous et entre
tous ceux qui le souhaiteront dans cet
ensemble citoyens et enfin cinquième
engagement
les français qui voudront s'engager avec
nous ils pourront le faire directement
sur notre site et nous les contacterons
et nous les associerons à l'action
historique que nous avons à conduire
juridiquement il ne se substitue pas
on
ne se substitue pas à nos formations
fondatrices
ils seront engagés est engagé c'est le
plus beau mot de citoyens qu'on puisse
trouver et donc chacun des français
pourra participer à cette action
je veux enfin dire ceci est mon dernier
mot cette soirée pour beaucoup d'entre
nous c'est l'accomplissement ou le début
de l'accomplissement d'un rêve
d'un rêve dont nous croyons qu'il peut
et qu'il doit changer la vie
démocratique de notre pays
ce rêve n'aurait pas été possible sans
une solidarité entre tous ceux qui le
partage
et je veux à tous leur dire ma gratitude
mais je voudrais si vous le permettez
exprimé en particulier cette gratitude à
trois personnes deux qui sont là au
premier rang
philippe grangeon qui a porté dès le
début ce concept de maison commune
et richard ferrand dont la patience et
la volonté d'en a fallu ont été
décisives
quant au troisième il n'est pas là mais
ne doutez pas que sa pensée son
influence est accompagnée et parfois
devancé nos efforts celui qui est pour
aujourd'hui et j'espère pour demain
président de la république française
emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]